[Music]
Cambridge England 2009 world-renowned
physicist Stephen Hawking threw a party
canapes were prepared champagne board
but friends and family weren't on the
guest list
the only people invited were time
travelers here's somebody who worked on
the physics of black holes worked on the
physics of time and he thought to
himself if time travelers exist they
might all come together at one specific
point in space and time for a party the
invites gave a place date and time but
they weren't sent out until after the
party happened but he only invited
people from the future who could travel
back into the past professor Hawking
waited and waited and waited
unfortunately no one showed up is this
proof that time travel doesn't exist
well though maybe maybe he's just known
in the futures having thrown really
crappy parties a party without guests
isn't much of a party good time
travelers jump back in time and liven
things up we're all moving into the
future that is in essence time travel
you're traveling into the future at 60
seconds per minute kind of a cop-out
though when you talk about time travel
you want to talk about leap frogging
into the future or going into the past
if we want to go to Stephen Hawking's
party which is now in the past how do we
do that
one way would be to change our passage
through time according to Albert
Einstein that's possible a hundred years
ago
Einstein started a Scientific Revolution
which requires us to let go of our
common sense ideas about what space and
time are so instead of thinking about
universe is a three-dimensional place
that just changes over time
we should think of reality is this
four-dimensional place called space-time
if you stop and think about it all of
your observations of time are directly
coupled to watching something move in
space right what is a day really but the
rising in the setting of the Sun or an
hour but the motion of a hand on a clock
the three dimensions of space are linked
with one dimension of time making a
four-dimensional space-time continuum
four wannabe time travelers that's good
news
it means motion through space is
connected to motion through time we've
moved through space-time not space or
time and the way this works is that if
I'm standing still and I'm not moving
through space very quickly then I move
through time as fast as is possible
this DeLorean doesn't look like it's
moving but it is it's moving through
time the car its driver and the road
it's parked on are all moving through
time at the same rate second by second
but when the driver hits the gas
some of that movement through time is
converted into movement through space as
soon as I have motion through space some
of my intrinsic movement through
space-time is now taken up by that
motion as I move faster through space I
move slower through time scientists call
this time dilation
[Music]
it turns fast-moving humans into time
travelers March 27 2015 astronaut scott
Kelly traveled to the International
Space Station
his year-long mission was to study the
effects of spaceflight on the human body
Scott was the perfect candidate because
back on earth
he had an identical twin mark they did
this for a variety of reasons to explore
the effects of space travel and
weightlessness on the human body using
as control and experiment as possible
lack of gravity wasn't the only
difference between the twins Scott was
orbiting Earth at 17,000 miles an hour
so compared to his earthbound twin Scott
moved forwards through time this time
travel into the future isn't just an
abstract physics concept Scott the
orbiting twin literally jumped into the
future by a fraction of a second when
Scott finally returned back to earth
because of his rapid speed he aged just
a little bit slower than his brother and
he was actually younger by a tiny
fraction of a second
17,000 miles an hour is fast but to jump
more than a fraction of a second into
the future Scott needed to go way faster
what if Scott Kelly had wanted to let
the earth age a thousand years while he
was in orbit for one year how fast would
he have had to orbit the earth to do
that and it turns out he'd have to orbit
at almost the speed of light to put it
in perspective just how fast that is the
fastest human piloted vehicle in history
was Apollo 10 that went at 25,000 miles
per hour you would need to go more than
25,000 times faster than that that's
pretty fast in the future we might try
to build a spaceship with advanced
propulsion capable of light speed
but the laws of physics won't make it
easy it would take an infinite amount of
energy to accelerate something a car a
marble a galaxy whatever to the speed of
light and so for that reason we think
that the speed of light is itself a
truly unbreakable speed
if you want to take a human-sized
spacecraft and accelerate it to ten
percent of the speed of light let alone
90% or 99% of the speed of light it
requires more energy than humanity as
ever used in its entire existence and
probably will ever use in its entire
existence jumping forward in time isn't
simple but the physics of the universe
make it possible going close to the
speed of light slingshots you into the
future faster but it does not take you
to the past in any way it's not a way to
go backwards in time and visit anyone's
party a super-fast
time-traveling spaceship can't take us
back to Hawking's party but what about a
time machine that exists out in the
cosmos